all right what do you got for me buddy
hey coming at you from pittsburgh rich
what's up in pittsburgh uh
we finally got some spring here today
very nice can't complain about that but
uh
so what do you want a great reset
situation man
i'm i'm 56 years old
and
i've never seen
the crap that i'm seeing now and i i
mean that in a
not a global sense
obviously but
personally um yeah
i'm just kind of crap like what are you
seeing
seeing exactly
the like the
the loss of the
society's mind like what the hell are
people thinking do you think the whole
mass formation psychosis
is a reality the stuff that dr malone
and uh mccullough were talking about uh
i i don't know that
i don't know that that's the right name
but
i believe that people are
believing what they're told to believe
i'll put it that way i i can't i think
on a scale like we've never seen before
but it's like i get that they got away
with that back in the day when the
families would sit around like the radio
or like the one black and white tube tv
that they had and you know they would
consume whatever they were told because
it's all they had now right right but i
mean today we live in a world where it's
like okay you can compare information
right you can go right to
the head of the guy that that [ __ ]
wrote the code for the mrna vaccine and
you know he'll sit on a three-hour
podcast and talk to another guy about
exactly what his thoughts are you
wouldn't have got that back in the 40s
or 50s or 60s right well i mean i guess
my thinking is the the problem is even
bigger than that i mean
western society has been
demoralized
everything that
everything that people read see and hear
appears to be driven
in a sense to just
bring
people's
morals down bring people's thoughts down
uh
you're you know going to speak
basically firsthand
fears fears how you control people
that guy over there has weapons of mass
destruction let's go get them oh yeah
and you know they goose people a couple
of decades ago you know recently it was
oh there's this
coming we're all gonna die like i
i'm not stupid but the way they were
selling it when it first happened it was
like
okay this could be bad call my parents
i'm like look don't go anywhere we'll
take care of groceries and drop them off
and [ __ ] like just stay home we're not
sure what's going on just yet
and kind of took a preventative approach
to it until you're like okay well we're
the bodies and you know what's going on
here right like they keep stripping away
all these freedoms
i work in healthcare and and i
i to this day i still see people driving
around by themselves in their car and i
think with a mask
with a mask on and i think well if it
was pandemic were real wouldn't we be
seeing biohazard containers for used
masks
or we'd be good people just throw them
on the street now yeah they're i i i
just say people that vote for liberalism
and not having domestic fuel and oil
production that will wear mass take 17
jabs and then throw their mask on the
floor right right and think nothing of
it but but they're totally fine walking
to the grocery store touching their cart
and everything else in the store and
then
you know wiping their nose
cross-contaminating themselves there's
no
it just doesn't add up and it's
the the other thing that i've noticed is
a lot of your your talks on your other
on your youtube channel i mean it's
about
the female aspect and
you know not only are men being crushed
but women as well i mean where are their
minds they they're they've been trained
with this western
well they've been indoctrinated to no
longer
seek a
male they've been told to think for
themselves they've been put into the
workforce they've been paying their
taxes they've been told they need a man
like a fish needs a bicycle right and
now you know we see
that really affecting society like
one of the isms that happens to be a
problem is the whole feminism you know
movement which is not about equality
it's about female dominance
and superiority now right and there's a
lot of fallout that's come at the
results of all of that it's been
interesting right well it kind of echoes
what happened with the welfare state
down here in the states you know we we
introduced
you want to hear a welfare state story
you should move to canada and see what
goes on over here dude well i mean we
don't need dads anymore down here you
know it's
they're not needed anywhere in the west
right anymore it's you know you can go
have your kids you can have a guy knock
you up and you'll be financially taken
care of either by him or the state or a
combination of both even if you don't
want to have a man do it the
conventional way you can just go to a
clinic and they'll just
push a button and bam yeah and i guess
at the end of the day it's all a perfect
storm i mean peop society's been
conditioned for the last
at least 30 to 50 years just to do
whatever they want and
government's going to take care of you
bingo i got a lot of people waiting to
hop in here and there's someone here
that disagrees take care i want to pull
in so i'll let you go for now thanks bud
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you